estas imágenes publicadas por el
Ministerio de defensa ruso muestran los
cráteres de los proyectiles y los
escombros alrededor de la central
nuclear de saborilla después de que el
sitio fuera atacado durante el fin de
semana Rusia y Ucrania se han
responsabilizado mutuamente por el
bombardeo a la instalación las
autoridades respaldadas por Moscú alegan
que las fuerzas ucranianas atacaron el
lugar con un lanzacohetes múltiple
dañando las líneas eléctricas y una
tubería de agua kiev por su parte dice
que los bombardeos rusos dañaron tres
sensores de radiación e hirieron a un
empleado de la planta el presidente de
Ucrania pidió a la comunidad
internacional Que responda con sanciones
al sector nuclear ruso
ninguna nación del mundo puede sentirse
Segura Cuando un estado terrorista
dispara contra una central nuclear
viendo lo que era si Ocurre algo
irreparable nadie detendrá el viento que
propagará la contaminación radiactiva
el mayor complejo de energía nuclear de
Europa está bajo control ruso desde
marzo Pero sigue siendo operado por
técnicos ucranianos el organismo
internacional de energía atómica afirma
que los ataques a la central ponen de
manifiesto un riesgo muy real de
catástrofe nuclear el secretario general
de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez Pide a ese
organismo que estabilice la situación en
saprillac cualquier ataque a una central
nuclear es algo suicida espero que la
Hoya pueda tener acceso a la planta y
ejercer las competencias que le
corresponden
la compañía de energía nuclear de
Ucrania acusa a Rusia de intentar cortar
la energía de la planta que proporciona
al país el 20% de su electricidad